Y
IN ISRAEL, NOT JUST DB.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IT WAS NOT FAR ALONG THERE -- OF
OUR LONG AGO, THE ANTI-FREE
SPEECH LUNATICS WERE CENTERING
THE TRUTH ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
COVID-19 BECAUSE IT DID NOT FOR
THEIR DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PRE-NEW DEAL NARRATIVE.
ARE NEW CALLS FOR THESE TECH
GIANTS TO LOSE THEIR SPECIAL
LEGAL PROTECTION.
WE TOLD YOU ABOUT SECTION 230.
RUNNING IS NOT WITH MARK, PRETTY
GOOD INSIGHT INTO ALL OF THIS,
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO OF FLORIDA.
BY THE MAKE A YOU HAVE AN
IMPORTANT RACE IN 2022.
UNLESS IT HURTS YOU, I SUPPORT
YOU WINNING.
WE NEED YOU IN FLORIDA AND WE
NEED YOU IN WASHINGTON.
SO THANKS FOR BEING BACK WITH
US.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: LET'S GET INTO BIG
TECH WITHHELD INFORMATION ON
HUNTER'S LAPTOP.
CHOOSING SIDES, WHAT DO THEY GET
THIS PROTECTION?
>> THEY HAVE BECOME THE NEW
GATEKEEPERS OF THE AMERICAN
POLITICS.
FIVE COMPANIES IN AMERICA NOW
HAVE THE POWER TO BASICALLY BITE
ANYBODY OUT AND SENDS THEM.
AMAZON, GOOGLE, FACEBOOK,
TWITTER, THEY ALL GET TOGETHER
AND DECIDE, APPLICANT VEDIC --
GET TOGETHER AND DECIDE, WE ARE
GOING TO WIPE NOBODY OUT.
YOU ARE DONE.
YOU CAN'T COMMUTED TO OUTSIDE
WORLD.
MORE THAN THAT, THEY KNOW HAVE
PUT THEMSELVES IN A POSITION OF
DETERMINING WHAT NEWS CAN BE
RE-REPORTED.
REMEMBER THOSE ARTICLES ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN?
THEY WOULD NOT LET THE "NEW YORK
POST" STORY, SPREAD.
WE GO BACK AND REMOVE A BAN ON
SOURCE ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF THE
COVID-19 VIRUS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
PROVEN TO BE UNTRUE.
THIS IS THE DANGER HERE.
YOU HAVE UNELECTED,
UNACCOUNTABLE ANONYMOUS PEOPLE
DECIDING WHAT WE ARE ALLOWED TO
SAY TO ONE ANOTHER AND WHAT WE
ARE ALLOWED TO SHARE.
THAT IS A VERY DANGERS MOMENT.
HAVE ASSUMED BASICALLY
GOVERNMENTAL POWERS WITHOUT
BEING ACCOUNTABLE TO ANYONE.
>> Sean: LET'S ME AT -- LET ME
MOVE ON TO THE CORONAVIRUS AND
WHAT FAUCI NEW AND WHEN HE KNEW
IT AND NIH MONEY GOING TO THAT
WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
I DUNNO ABOUT YOU, SENATOR, BUT
THIS MAKES MY BLOOD BOIL.
WE COULD HAVE ACTUALLY PAID FOR
THIS.
>> HERE'S WHAT WE KNEW FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING, RIGHT?
THIS IS WHAT WE KNEW FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING.
IT LENDS TO SOME LEVEL OF
INCLUSION AT LEAST.
YOU HAVE A VIRUS THAT WE KNOW
THE CHINESE ARE EXPERIMENTING
WITH IN THAT LAB IN A LAB THAT
WE KNOW THAT HAS SAFETY
PROBLEMS.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT THAT MESSING
AROUND WITH VIRUSES HAS LED TO
OUTBREAKS IN THE PAST BUT THAT
HAPPENS WITH SARS BACK IN THE
DAY, TWO SEPARATE OUTBREAKS FROM
RESEARCHERS THAT WERE INFECTED.
COINCIDENCE OUT OF COINCIDENCE,
THIS OUTBREAK STARTED IN THE
VERY CITY WHERE THAT LAB WAS
LOCATED.
IT IS LIKE THE SIZE OF
MANHATTAN.
THERE'S NO, BAT CAVE THERE.
BY THE MAKE A UNDER SARS THAT
THEY FOUND THE ANIMAL WAS
PRINTED WITHIN FOUR MONTHS.
UNDER MERS, THEY FOUND THE
ANIMAL, SPREAD IT WITHIN NINE
MONTHS.
TO THIS DAY, THE CHINESE HAS NOT
SECOND IS THE ANIMAL THAT FIRST
SPREAD IT OVER TO A HUMAN BEING
THAT YOU PUT ALL THAT TOGETHER,
AND THAT IS WHY A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAY, A MINIMUM, A MINIMUM, THE
LAB LEAK THEORY IS AT LEAST AS
CREDIBLE AS THE FACT THAT IT
WOULD CARRY OVER NATURALLY, IF
NOT MORE SO BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THE
SAME QUESTION I ASKED LINDSEY
GRAHAM WITH HUNTER'S WORK AND
JOE SAYING HE NEVER TALK TO HIS
SON ABOUT THE FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS WITH NO EXPERIENCE
MAKING ALL OF THIS MONEY AND
RUSSIA AND CHINA.
DO WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THIS
PRESIDENT BEING COMPROMISED
POTENTIALLY ON NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUES?
I'M PRETTY CERTAIN THAT THAT
MEDIA THE MOP THAT THEY ARE, IF
IT WAS A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT,
WOULD BE ALL OVER THIS CONFLICT
OF INTEREST, SHALL WE CALL IT?
>> WITH A LEADING STORY IN EVERY
OUTLET TONIGHT.
IF THAT WERE DONALD TRUMP, I
WOULD NOT BE SITTING IN THE
SENATE RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL BE IN IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS RIGHT NOW.
IT WOULD BE LEADING THE NEWS
TABS AND EVERY MAJOR MEDIA
OUTLETS.
BUT IT WOULD BE THE TOP STORY IN
THE COUNTRY.
THEY WOULD BE ALL OVER IT,
ABSENTLY PICNIC SHOWS AT TWO
THINGS.
IT IS SOMETHING TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
I THINK IT ALSO EXPOSES THE
EXTERNAL -- EXTRAORDINARY
HYPOCRISY AND JOURNALISM.
>> Sean: SAID JOURNALISM IS
DEAD IN THAT YEAR 2007.
THAT PROBABLY MEANS I HAVE BEEN
ON THE AIR TOO LONG.
LAST QUESTION.
YOU MADE COMMENTS ABOUT UFOs
AND I'M JUST INTRIGUED BY THIS
TOPIC AND I JUST WANT TO, YOU
KNOW, THEY ARE SAYING, THERE'S
NO EVIDENCE OF THAT AND YOU SEE
ALL THESE VIDEOS AND I'M
BEGINNING TO THINK THAT WHAT IS
THAT?
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
LOOK AT KEPT PEOPLE IMMINENTLY
SENT ME SOMETHING ABOUT
EXTRATERRESTRIALS AND LITTLE
GREEN MEN.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE NOT
HOURS.
>> Sean: BE CAREFUL, SENATOR
PERDUE ARE GOING TO BE CALLED
RACIST.
JUST SAYING.
>> THE GREEN PART OR THE LITTLE
PART?
>> Sean: I HAVE NO IDEA.
PROBABLY ON EVERY PART.
>> THESE THINGS FLYING AROUND.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT THEY ARE.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH YOU.
SENATOR COTTON WE ARE GOING TO
BE FOLLOWING YOUR RAC